[Music]
Brooklyn nine-nine is back for season
six on NBC
Terry Crews dishes on the hit show being
picked up by NBC just one day after it
was canceled by Fox and the surprising
Hollywood heavyweights who came to its
defense first of all I ran into him at
the Writers Guild Awards right before
the Oscars and he grabbed me and he was
like I love this show and then when it
got canceled he like took it upon
himself to put a tweet out like this is
amazing they have everything you know if
someone should pick this up right away
and I'm like with the endorsement from
Guillermo of who is the oscar-winning
director then a lin-manuel Miranda who
is the greatest playwright we have
living today and Mark Hamill Luke
Skywalker said they want the show back
man let me tell you something and the
whole of the Internet
it feels so good the actor also revealed
what fans can expect from season six
more the same but now that Jake and Amy
are married it's gonna be a really cool
cool thing et caught up with Cruz at the
premiere of his new flick
sorry to bother you hey Kash almost long
I got away from my money God made this
land for all of us greedy people like
you want to hog it to yourself and your
family and me and my family yeah Cassius
I'm your uncle let me tell you something
you think you're ready but you're not
ready it's one of the most unique
beautiful absolutely incredible films
I've ever been a part of it's the movie
you didn't know you needed and while
Cruz is killing it on red carpets these
days he admitted he had his fair share
of odd jobs I work for a refrigeration
company I was putting for the
refrigerators on roofs I was founded in
street signs I would get a lot of
security
I've also did courtroom sketches I've
did all kinds of job everything and
let me tell you doing what I do right
now I wouldn't even call it work
[Music]